Today's theme is holiness and the body.
Four things you need to know about holiness and the body. Ready?
If you're taking notes, number one,
God's call to holiness isn't just to your spirit,
it's to your body as well. Now, this is very clear from
scripture. It's literally all over the New Testament. Let me quote a few for you.
All right? "Don't you know that your body is a temple of the Holy Spirit?" 1
Corinthians. "I pray God your whole spirit and soul and body be preserved
blameless." 1 Thessalonians, chapter five.
"Cleanse yourselves of all filthiness of flesh and spirit."
2 Corinthians, chapter seven. "Offer your bodies a living sacrifice, holy and
acceptable." Romans 12. "Don't let sin reign in your mortal body so you
obey it in its desires." Romans six. Are you convinced yet? All right.
I want you to notice how practical holiness is.
God recognizes that you're not just a spirit, you have a body.
He's not giving you some mystical experience that doesn't touch where you
actually live. Holiness is really where it's
practical and the rubber meets the road in your life.
I want you to note that the body is called to be a part of the
project of holiness. It's not irrelevant to it.
In the early church, there was a Gnostic heresy that said that matter was
lesser and evil and only spirit was pure.
And Gnostic teachers compared the spirit actually to a jewel located in the pigpen
of the body.
Some of them even taught that Jesus didn't have a physical body because they
thought that having matter, having a physical body would've made him
impure. You know what? That's hogwash.
God's call to holiness is to your spirit and to the body you
have. Having a body is no reason you can't be holy.
Paul even says, "Whether you eat or drink or whatever you
do, do it all to the glory of God."
So if you've just kind of lived your whole life assuming you're always going to be
defeated by the urges of your body, then you need to understand that God has a call
to holiness for you. God knows you live in a body, and he
created this physical flesh with a purpose and with a
potential to be holy. When you are raised
in the new heavens and new Earth, you'll have a glorified body, and it'll still be
a body of actual flesh like the one Jesus has now, and he ate
broiled fish with his disciples. Right?
God is so mighty that he can produce holiness even in a
person that's limited by an actual physical body like yours.
Number two, bodily drives and temptations are not
incompatible with holiness. While God
calls you to holiness in your body, it's important to
understand that holiness is not physical perfection or immunity
to temptation. Our physical bodies have been affected by the fall,
but they in themselves are not sinful.
Physical drives for food and rest and drink and sex
are not incompatible with holiness.
Jesus had all of those, and he's a perfect example of
holiness. Jesus got tired. Jesus needed food. Jesus got hungry.
He got thirsty. He was tempted in all the same ways that we are,
but he didn't sin. He lived in holiness.
So if you're tracking with me here, temptations to sin are
not incompatible with holiness. Jesus was tempted, and he's
a perfect example of holiness. So track
with me. Temptation isn't sin. Noticing isn't sin.
Even attraction isn't sin. You think Jesus was attracted by the
idea of bread after fasting 40 days in the wilderness?
You think he was attracted to the idea of not dying on the cross even though it was
the will of the Father for him? You better believe it.
Sin comes not when we notice or when we're tempted or even attracted to something
that wouldn't be God's will for us.
Sin comes when we choose what we know is not holy.
Number three,
holiness in the body is about surrender followed by
discipline. The Bible is very clear that our bodies should be
surrendered to holiness. Right? In a lot of
people, the body rules over the mind.
And for some people, it's like there's no gap between instinct and response.
And the smaller that gap between instinct and response is, the more like the
animals we are. Right? You need to surrender your body to the Lord and
ask him to help you to install a gap between your instincts and
drives and responses, a gap in which your
purified, empowered mind and will can
activate and come into play. Learning to create and use that gap
between instinct and response is self-discipline.
Paul said, "I strike a blow to my body and make it my slave
so that after I have preached to others, I myself will not be
disqualified for the prize." Self-discipline.
Number four, your body can be holy while you're waiting for
redemption. Now, remember,
put on your possibility glasses here.
God would not issue a call to your physical body to holiness
if he was not willing to create it in you or not able.
Dr. Phil Brown says, "God who knows our frame and empowers our inner
life will not command the impossible."
Someday, your body will be delivered from the effects of sin and set free
to glorious perfection. But for now, you can live in holiness
if you'll capture those drives, understand temptation's
limitations, and discipline your body while you're
waiting for redemption.
I'll see you tomorrow.